all right Instagram began as a digital
photo app now an estimated 800 million
people used the social network every
month from 500 million users in the
summer of 2016 that growth is largely
driven by video chief operating officer
Marty Levine is managing the expansion
of the Facebook owned company as
Instagram celebrates its seventh
anniversary we spoke with Levine in New
York and we talked about the measures
her business is taking to help its
platform keep its platform safe for
users how do you manage a community
that's growing so quickly so we're
really focused on making sure that we
maintain our kind of community that
we've had we've had a really kind
inclusive and welcoming community at a
time when Instagram is growing faster
than ever its chief operating officer
Marty Levine says the social network is
focused on one core principle kindness
what we have done is we have created
technology for kindness tools that allow
you to feel safe on the platform you can
delete comments filter out words that
you might not want to see in your
comments we're even using machine
learning to train the system to filter
out the most impulsive comments that
might appear so are you censoring some
of the comments I wouldn't call it
censoring we are taking out some of the
words that really would be in violation
of our community standards anyways by
helping to give people control over
their space we feel that they'll feel
more comfortable telling their stories
so lift you higher Instagram is taking
this kindness campaign beyond the screen
on your smartphone creating vibrant
murals in 10 cities around the world
so instagrams now in the business of
street art well we are in the business
of working with other people too in to
inspire their street argaï
we want to encourage having a kind
inclusive and welcoming community on
Instagram but also in the world 500
million people around the world now use
Instagram every day 250 million of those
users post stories the tool the company
developed to rival its social media
competitor snapchat and as the number of
users grows so does the number of
advertisers which has doubled in size in
just six months
is there political advertising on
Instagram there is political advertising
on Instagram candidates have used it to
connect with potential voters Instagram
uses the same technology that Facebook
has and so you can target people on both
Facebook and on on Instagram to put your
message out there and that is really
useful because people should understand
what what a candidate stands for what a
candidate is about who that person is
what their character is like what where
they stand on different issues do you
look at what's happened with Facebook
and the scrutiny that they're facing on
Capitol Hill from director Muller and
you say we've got to look now at
Instagram in a different way and make
sure we have protections that it's not
manipulated for political purposes well
I think Mark Zuckerberg in his recent
post has talked about a lot of this it
is a new challenge for internet
communities to have to deal with nation
states attempting to subvert elections
he talked about the fact that we are
going to be more transparent when it
comes to political advertising he's also
cooperating with Congress and with the
special counsel to help them understand
what transpired here there's also been a
lot of scrutiny lately about the culture
in Silicon Valley the treatment of women
in Silicon Valley and some of the other
big tech companies as a leader you look
at that and say what what needs to
change well I think it's really
important to continue to encourage women
to be a part of the tech community when
there are more women in the tech
community I think things will most
definitely change I think being part of
Facebook Instagram has been an
incredible experience share
Samberg is leading the company and
internally we have lots of conversations
about unconscious bias we have strong
biases against women being leaders and
we have strong biases against race they
have lots of conversations about
supporting women and people of all
different kinds of backgrounds in the
workplace I think that we have a lot of
work to do and this is something that we
are most definitely focused on and I am
focused on it Instagram that's part of
why they have this kind comments section
- which is now you can find on Instagram
but they've had rapid growth I mean you
mr. Charlie Rose deed I am you are your
I'd saw this great post that you had the
other day look look at Charlie back in
the day at the White House my goodness
what year was that I don't know it
wasn't yesterday one of the reasons I
think it's easy for so many people to
use it's just so easy to use yeah you
can post any photos you want right away
yeah I never loved him you can find more
of our conversation about women and
technology including Marni's tips for
getting your foot in the door by heading
to our CBS this morning Instagram more
of the conversation there